welcome back to new rockstars this is
bite size questions now that i have to
answer
all right ooh this one's all oh this was
mailed to us
yes you can email us at our po box it's
below direct boston philable
14 million six hundred thousand and five
times i've been thinking does captain
have the odin force
princess the power thor had in ragnarok
because in thor one odin said
whoever holds this hammer if he be
worthy shall possess the powers of thor
since cap is worthy wouldn't he possess
that sincerely
jackson casey p.s sorry about the
construction paper i guess i'll have to
call dunder mifflin
limitless paper in a paperless world
thank you so much
thanks jackson and a great question we
are happy to clear this up because it is
a detail we have overlooked in past
videos
video that i worked on with marina and
poor marina had to go up and host this
video with a with kind of a little
fact over sight that was totally my
fault but she did a great job with this
video
um yes you are corrected pointed out
that odin's worthiness
charm in thor one does say that whoever
wields this hammer should they be worthy
will possess the powers
of thor and uh because cap
the mcu has decided he is worthy there
was that little detail in
age of ultron where he's able to budget
and then of course in avengers end game
he picks it up
and he is able to summon lightning with
it meaning
uh he is worthy of the powers of thor
including
the god of thunder powers which is just
inherent lightning summoning abilities
so yes uh due to odin's worthiness charm
and thor one
cap is worthy of the powers of thor
including lightning powers
and then also technically thor doesn't
even need the hammer he does
to do it so maybe captain just summoned
it i think he becomes the god of thunder
the moment he picks up the hammer good
answer yeah good job and thank you
jackson what if
cap could still only just budge the
hammer even an end game
it's just like you watch out
thanos coming your way big guy j.r lopez
asks when spider-man
whips around uh does he leave webs
everywhere or does it just dissolve
you got to spread that seed until your
sack is empty would there be webs all
around
new york um so stan lee established
pretty early on in the spider-man comics
in the 60s that spider-man's web fluid
dissolves after an hour
so as after an hour starts to go by it
it gets really dry and brittle and
eventually just kind of like
disintegrates into dust it's something
that peter parker he didn't design it
this way
he actually tried to make the spider
webbing
more long-lasting and durable because he
wanted to try to sell it to make money
off it
but he couldn't figure out a way to do
it so he's just like dang it okay well
this is the best i can do
so that way it kind of establishes how
new york isn't covered in in
gooey gooey webbing forever and ever and
why a number of criminals get away if
the
if they yeah the cops got to show up
fast yeah it's kind of like a the
pizza's free
yeah i did my part great and then one
last one
lucas mucus asks eric what's my clunky
what does my clunky mean all right so
mcclunkey reenact it real quick
over my dead body my clunky
how dare you this is in a new hope
uh it's a greedo and han solo standoff
in the mos eisley cantina
and the scene that has been notoriously
changed over and over again by lucas in
the 97
special edition release they he added
the bolt of
greedo's blaster fire to make it look
like greedo shot first when in the
original han just shot first
preemptively
latest version on disney plus they added
yet again
another detail of greedo saying mcclunky
and people were like what the hell does
this mean
well according to brian young at
lucasfilm on twitter he established that
mcclunkey
is a hattie's word translating to this
will be the end of you
uh so that whole phrase yeah the whole
phrase mcclunky
and it's kind of ironic obviously
because it's gonna be the end of him in
this moment but it's it doesn't come out
of nowhere because he pointed out back
in phantom menace
jar jar is goofing around and he pisses
off subulba like
getting that crap all over his table and
sabolpa jumps on him and he says
so yeah so it's been established in star
wars canon before so if you had a real
sharp easter egg uh
you you wouldn't have batted an eye at
mcclunky being in there other than
they edited it again just leave the
scene alone just leave it alone
the boy alone so there you go that's
what that's what the clunky means
do i think it belongs in that scene uh
yeah it probably just deserves to be
left alone
uh deathstroke4769 asks in captain
america's civil war
during peggy carter's funeral one
pallbearer has gray hair could that be
old cap i remember this
okay yeah yeah yeah yeah um no
next question okay just kidding so it
looks like it could be capped from the
back
um but a set photo actually shows us the
front side and it's a totally different
actor he has a mustache
it's a different person however you
could argue like oh maybe it's cabbage
with a mustache
like he parted us on the other side
maybe he got a mustache to hide himself
like he's like i can't run into myself
so but i'm gonna go to the same funeral
where i know
i know so dumb well i also don't like
this version if it is him because
that means that we have to go with it's
the same timeline that cap
went back and it's the same timeline and
that's problematic because that means he
sat out a bunch of like really
horrible events this is a tuffy
[Music]
horrible things happen yeah and he just
dated his like grand niece
i'm gonna say no um which means that we
go with the alternate timeline
for endgame which is what the directors
say so narp
lastly harry asks or hari asks what
happened to wakanda in the five years
that t'challa was dusted was raimonda
trying to run things for five years or
was she dusted too
okay so t'challa and shuri were dusted
okay that's
for sure um queen ramonda and mbaku are
alive first they stayed alive when
there's a vacancy
in uh the king role the the leadership
role you do
a warrior falls ritual to see who will
be the new leader
so it's presumable that uh mbaku would
try to get that title because he
challenged to challenge that's right he
was like the runner up
yeah he was the runner-up and he was
really close to winning it's presumable
that
in t'challa's absence he would come back
do it again and either
be totally unchallenged because everyone
was like um i saw this last time like
i'm not like you good
yeah or he would be challenged but then
still win
yeah because he's a badass because he
was second place with the whole
killmonger thing
in black panther and also uh in the
battle against thanos like he
came together in the end and he was like
okay cool so he's a hero again yeah he's
respected
super pop super popular super pops dude
yeah
and also just like be stand up guy and
rule for the next five years
and like hold down the fort we
understand if like there's now a power
struggle when t'challa comes back he's
like you've been gone for five years my
friend right
i've been kicking ass here he's like gdp
is up are you sure you want to come back
because things are kind of shitty he's
like we instituted universal basic
income we got a couple other dark things
we are human rights violations
but no never in wakanda never the trains
run on time the trains run on time all
right well great
thanks for joining us to this week's
episode of the big question question
thank you to marina for subbing up for
philip you did a great job you always do
a great job you can always send us your
big questions using the hashtag
bigquestions on social media follow us
at new rockstars on all social media
uh subscribe to new rockstars here on
youtube and if you love this show
not just like it not just comment saying
that you love it share it around your
friends that's how we got to get the
word out on this
because we want to be doing more of this
stuff asking more of these questions
because i love doing this kind of
research even though it scares me it
scares me
hey we should do this again sometime all
right uh and you can get a big question
wherever you get your podcasts
thanks for joining and we'll see you
next time can we do the air close
yeah perfect tension perfect picture
don't look at me
[Music]
you